welcome back uh today we're going to go
through the lab for chapter 10 the the
Deep learning lab and we'll see that uh
the this is deep learning so it's
supervised uh problems like we've seen
throughout much of the course but the
way the code uh the code will look
slightly different uh because we're not
using pyit learn uh to fit these models
we're using uh one of the more popular
uh open- Source deep learning packages
uh the torch package so um we'll see
that the you know the way we set up
problems is going to be slightly
different to the psychic learn it's
going to be a little more complicated um
so we but we'll see several examples and
we will see enough so that we'll see the
the repeating pattern but
okay um so as usual we have our Imports
at the beginning um all of these ones up
here in the cell we've seen before and
then we have some some torch specific
Imports now we haven't included to torch
as a dependency to islp so you'll have
to use pip to install a few packages is
there are a few like torch and you'll
see below torch Vision torch metrics
torch info only four or five and we'll
have instructions on the web page how to
do that but we already saw how to
install packages with Pip
earlier okay so um let's see the uh one
of the important one of the most
important things in this module is this
um NN this NN stands for uh neural
network and we'll we'll see later when
we specify our loss function right
because it's a supervised problem we
really just have to specify the loss
function we're going to use this the
module part uh the module class from NN
as the as a key thing so that's going to
help us set up all the comple all the
different hidden layers of the neural
network um and so so that's going to be
one of the key modules part of that um
there are quite a few Imports so I don't
think we should dwell too much on them
another key concept is this idea of a
tensor data Set uh so unlike earlier
chapters where we use data frames and
numpy arrays there are sort of specific
forms of the data set for torch and
that's because uh torch or other o
packages uh for fitting deep learning
models they will um they will use data
in a different fashion right they'll use
the mini batch Paradigm or something
like that so there's a lot of sort of
overhead that these packages have
written to deal with that so when we
we'll take arrays and form them into
tense tensor data sets and that's going
to be enough to tell torch how to get
the data to where it needs to go so
torch is a is a fairly general purpose
deep learning library and just using
torch itself if we were to fit the
models it's requires effectively writing
stochastic gradient descent yourself so
that's kind of complicated there are
some helper packages in particular this
P torch lightning that makes it easier
to fit and so there's some sort of
common um patterns we'll use this
trainer that sort of encapsulates how to
once you know what what the data is and
what the network is how to actually fit
a model so we're going to use pytorch
lightning as a Helper and we've even
written uh in the islp package some
helpers for for pytorch um lightning and
that's are those are these these Imports
we hear from the is. torch so I think
Jonathan neural networks are quite
complex and they can do amazing range of
things so fortunately there's a lot of
these packages that have been written to
help us do it yes yeah I mean if we if
we were to do this from scratch right
like for instance in regression we could
have written regression from scratch but
if we were to do this from scratch it
would just take forever but now we have
these great packages that we can use to
we're going to start with a really
simple example so yes to see how things
work yeah yes so what we're going to
start with is um The Hitter data that
we've seen uh in uh other chapters um in
particular in linear regression and
model selection I think model selection
we talked about this one so um
one of the things that's you know that
these packages have is like psych learn
you can sort of change the metric you
can use to evaluate so we're going to
use mean absolute error instead of uh
mean squared error but okay so let's um
we're going to start off somewhere where
we were before that is we're going to
have a design Matrix and a response uh X
and A Y like we had in earlier chapters
and we'll see how this gets transformed
into Data that torch can read in so this
this X and this y are just like we saw
in earlier chapters we we've used model
SP uh to create
them uh and then we'll also make our
usual training and test split um and
we'll have torch can take a test data
set as well as a training data set even
a validation data set and we'll we'll
see how to do that
shortly okay so we can of course fit a
linear regression model we've already
seen that we're going to uh we're just
going to use this as a point of
comparison to see the accuracy how well
these things can do so we're going to
use a standardized lasso um and just
before you go on Jonathan just let's
remember the the error the mean absolute
error of 259 for the test data yeah that
and that's for simple linear regression
yeah and then we can compare that to the
lasso um the lasso was 25 259 versus 257
very CL very very close and we're going
to compare that after fitting a pretty
simple neural network
model okay so now we're going to build
our first Network and um this this is
going to use something that we have not
touched yet and that's using classes in
Python so we've written a lot of
functions in python or used a lot of
functions now we have to actually write
our own classes or more specifically
subclasses and let's take a look at what
that looks like so this keyword class is
this is the first time we've seen this
in the lab so how what is the format
what what are we doing here we're this
bit of code here is actually specifying
the the architecture of the neural
network and this is the way the torch
package um allows you to specify the the
network architecture and okay so as I
mentioned before we're going to use this
nn. module object and so what how to
read this line here is we're making a
new class called hitters model and
that's really going to be a
representation of the neuron Network
we're going to fit and it inherit from
nn. module and what's nice about this is
inheritance is that there's lots of
other thing there's lots of things an
object can do based on its methods here
we're going to Define two methods one
this double underscore init method this
is how the object is created and one the
forward map and this is really this is
what's key for the neural network this
is what's going to be you know when we
draw a picture like this uh with these
arrows uh this is evaluating this
forward map uh I'm just going to have a
very poor poor men Network there that AR
that Network there that's that's what
the forward mapping codes okay so let's
uh look at the key parts of this this
cell here because this is what we're
going to have to write each time we want
to fit a new network um so it's really
defining the forward map is all what we
we really need to do this init method we
do is where we do some of the setup so
in this case we're going to um have a
single hidden layer uh with 50 units so
um that's this 50 represents 50 units uh
there are 19 features so this nn. linear
says um this defines an uh an object
that Maps 19 features into 50 Dimensions
so there's 19 * 50 parameters in that
linear map plus 50 for The Intercept so
actually 20 * 50 1,000 parameters there
we apply the ru function to it and then
this Dropout you remember this randomly
in the fitting process just randomly set
some of the weights to zero and then
outputs the 50 parameters into a scale
of response the one here you're going to
find that these kinds of examples are
really helpful because when you want to
fit a neural network you'll go straight
to an example like this and you'll
change it so it matches your own example
yes yeah yeah so um okay and so this and
the sequential here this is meant to you
know to say that this map is going to be
composed of these four things in in
sequence okay so when we actually um now
we have enough to define the forward map
um so we actually first we flatten the
um x uh though I'm not con actually may
maybe not even need that in this case
but many for the image examples we may
need that and then we apply these four
Maps we defined and basically return
again the flat inv verion of the
array okay so now this is this has
defined the mapping for from uh features
those 19 features to an
outcome okay so we haven't said anything
about the response the response comes in
towards when we relate this to the loss
function uh right so now we have a way
if we give 19 features we have a way if
we know the weights of this network
we'll get an outcome and to train it
we're going to compare it to the actual
outcome
um so I guess I should say we get a
prediction when we pass the features
through and we'll compare to an outcome
so I'm just going
to uh jump to the
part where that's where the loss I'll
just I'll just jump actually let's look
at the summary J that's interesting that
shows you what's in the model okay yes
yes so to to actually um in sort of
create this object we have to like for
SK learn you have to construct the
estimator and we've made it so it takes
one argument that is the number of
features this is n there are 19 features
so hitters model 19 that will fully
specify what that Network looks like and
as treas Trevor said there's there's
often helper functions you can use to
sort of get a sense of what the network
is that you've specified this is
actually very helpful when you get more
complicated because well this is a
already a simple network but enough to
so the summary
function uh what we're going to do you
can ask for various things in the
summary but one of the most helpful
things is just to get a sense of what
each lay expect as input what it outputs
as output and how many parameters are in
that
layer okay so looking at our hitters
model here so this 175 that's uh well we
told it to use for the number of rows in
the input how many are in our training
set so um it takes um
175 cases with 19 features and produce a
prediction of 175 outcomes and you can
see sort of in a tree like fashion you
can see how the networks are are
specified and then if you if you go
through each row here you'll see you'll
see the numbers that you expect to see
so we see 19 a few times and then we see
the 50 at that point you've moved up to
the hidden layer with 50 units then the
Dropout gets applied there and so on
until eventually you get down to 1751
and that's your output yes and yeah un
for on the if you look at this on in a
web browser you'll see the actual number
of parameters and you can see for
instance that uh this this network here
will have um the two 1,000 parameters
that's 50 * 19 plus 50 for the B The
Intercept but they've been cut off um on
the tablet here okay let's see how well
it does Jonathan okay
um see how well it does and I guess okay
well I think I think we should it's
important enough to just sort of to see
how the data are passed into Tor okay I
was getting too excited you're excited
these parameters I was expecting some
good results uh yes that's fair but but
because as I said because data is
slightly different we have to we have to
package the data in a way that torch can
use it and so these XT train and X test
y train Etc are familiar to us they're
numpy arrays and we form different data
sets a training data set and a test a
test data set and that's ultimately what
is going to get fed into into into torch
okay okay so
um so the way this is specified is we're
going to have to it it's a bit
cumbersome I'll admit uh it's fair to
say but this pattern repeats itself so
once you can understand the few steps
then you can repeat this for other
problems so this simple data module is
what's going to tell torch how to read
in the data for stochastic radient
descent so here we're going to say we
want batches of size 32 and we we give a
training data set or training which is
we specified before the test data set
and we also have an optional validation
data set here we're just going to use
the test data validation but you can put
a a fraction here if you want 20% of the
the training data to be used for
validation and Jonathan correct me if
I'm wrong but simple data module is a
function we provide in the is package to
make this even easier make it even
easier yes
um okay and finally as I said we need to
specify the LW so we've also made a uh
there there's a few common losses we'll
see in the class one is the regression
loss that's squared error loss and one
is classification so this this part here
if you notice um it takes hit model and
remember this is the the network that
tells us how to make predictions uh and
regression says uh we're going to this
is how we're going to use that law in in
a regression loss so ultimately they
will be an argument for the the Y of the
hit train the the Y train will be
compared to hit model of x strain
through squared error that's what that
line means and well we'll also track the
mean absolute error okay so now I think
Trev we're just about ready to fit um
yes so the last step is to put this all
together to run stochastic radi newent
and that's what this cell is
doing okay so the last thing uh we
specified was this hit module that
specified was a regression problem and
this data module this is what we how we
told torch to run through the data um
with batch sizes of 32 Etc now we'll
tell if we want 50 Epoch and um a few
details about logging this this
callbacks argument here this is actually
what is going to allow us to make plots
as we as we go along the uh the the EPO
so this error tracker is just is another
little small helper thing we we add in
the isop package so that in our logs we
actually have the loss at every Epoch so
we can plot those um
okay that was a mouthful or several
mouthfuls okay so let's see let's see
how how it does are you ready I'm ready
okay okay so let's fit it and it'll give
us a bunch of messages that it's running
through the 50 e box there'll be about
50 lines here like this by the by the
way it's tedious to look at all these
blue things when it's all finished and
done but when you're sitting waiting for
the machine it's quite kind of nice see
in these popup sequentially showing the
it tells you work work is being done
your work is been done right yes okay um
so let's finally evaluate the uh the
performance I see the number uh test
means absolute error 229 229 and that's
I think we had 257 and 259 before yeah
so that's quite a bit better yes that's
quite a bit better yes so even though it
was much more complex to specify the
model it paid off in this case yes and
it may not pay off in every case but it
has here we'll see we'll see later okay
so now let's make a plot so the the
results when we we constructed something
to log the data and it just constructs
makes a a CSV file that we can load with
panda and we'll use that to make a few
plots let's take a look at at the plot
the um the error as a function of epoch
so here we're going to plot the mean
absolute error as a function of epoch
and actually well we maybe didn't need
to do 50 EPO here uh it sort of settled
down pretty quickly to um a point but in
this case training validation are about
the same probably have not overfit too
much it wasn't that complex a model I
guess notice how it's dancing around the
right because after each Epoch there's
been a you know you've used uh random
subsets of the batches of of the DAT to
update so there's there's a certain
element of noise in in this yes yeah all
of these all of these Network models use
stochastic gradient scent or some form
of stochastic gradient scent to do the
fitting Okay so that's a basic example
that shows you how to go from num arrays
to you know a simple single layer
Network
model